In this lesson, we've learned some new concepts that
can be summarized into four main points. Point one.
Genomic information is organized into both coding and non-coding
sequences. And it's these coding regions of genes that are
turned into proteins, which are one of the major
active components of cells. Point two. A gene is
transcribed into an MRNA copy that leaves the nucleus
and is translated by ribosomes in the cytoplasm into amino
acids that make up proteins. The code is
read in sets of three nucleotides called a codon
and this whole process is referred to as,
the central dogma. Point three. The genetic code is
non-overlapping and any change in the sequence may
or may result in overall changes to the amino
acids. And point four different versions of genes
are referred to as alleles. And although all humans
have two copies or two alleles of almost every gene. Many
different alleles can exist for any given gene in a population.